mona ou est-ce que vous vous situez on
aperçoit de plus en plus d'image proche
du boulevard périphérique
est ce que vous aviez eu accès à sur le
boulevard périphérique
en tous les cas du côté des barrières
anti-émeute que certains manifestants
temple de force en tous les cas on le
voit sur ces images en direct dans sa
victime là bas avec des canons à eau ici
à l'image en direct
c'est violent ce sont des scènes confuse
a priori que vous êtes un petit peu plus
loin de ce que vous arrivez à apercevoir
ce qui se passe
oui exactement grégory je me suis
éloigné de cette de la place de la
nation et je suis enfin les barricades
sont à quelques quelques centaines de
mètres de moi justement on a on a eu un
petit quelques frictions mais pour
l'instant de la part des
sapeurs-pompiers rien de très très
dangereux en tout cas pas une grande
confrontation et je vous le disais hé
bien ce portage il est composé de
plusieurs syndicats qui nous viennent de
tout est la france je suis justement
avec grégory chaillot de l'unsa du 78
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous à
14 heures il y avait cette réunion avec
l'intersyndicale des sapeurs pompiers et
le gouvernement qu'est ce que vous
attendez
en fait on a ça se portaient surtout sur
la prime de feu cette réunion
mais on pouvait souvent dangereuses en
éclat sans profession dangereuse et pour
cela comme la police il fallait à 28%
donc c'est le salaire de base c'est un
calcul ce qu'on appelle anciennement la
prime de feu toujours la prime de feu
est là tuez-le mans nous elle était à
19% depuis une trentaine d'années jamais
évolué et voyons la retraite arrivée
avec les poings et le commentaire le
système macron et un moment de salaire
comment des salaires bas dans la
fonction publique un faux bien que quand
même que le privé le sache
il ya un moment bas sur les primes
forcément pour essayer de remonter et
perdre le moins possible
voilà donc si ce qui a été fait
aujourd'hui donc on a demandé une plume
à 25% apparemment donc je vais pas
m'avancer on attend de savoir
l'intersyndicale nationale est ce
qu'elle va nous dire et apparemment on a
encore toujours sur la proposition à 25%
ce qui n'allait pas déjà cette semaine
et où la demande vraiment à 28% une
bonne fois pour toutes qui nous donne ce
qui nous revient de droit
ce qui n'a jamais été fait et ce qu'ils
aient eu c'est ce qu'on attend depuis
des années quoi il ya eu plusieurs
réunions justement à ce sujet la dengue
7 janvier
les sapeurs pompiers n'ont
vraisemblablement pas été convaincu par
ce qui a été à discuter argumenter
non parce qu'en fait on a un système de
retraite est assez compliqué parce qu'on
fait des bonifications il nous faut 27
ans de service opérationnel
justement c'est une année pour cinq
avant c'était 25 s'est monté à 27 de
cotisation on sait rien on nous donne
des grandes lignes on nous dit oui vous
allez pouvoir partir à 57 bien 57 ans
avaient qu avec la moitié de notre
retraite il ya trop d'inconnues
il ya la respecte article 36 qui a été
mis ou ne sais pas trop en gros ce
qu'ils veulent quand ils veulent nous ça
nous voit pas on ne vous vraiment des
choses très précises et comme pour
toutes les professions
rien n'est précis c'est pour ça que les
gens qui sont dans la rue il faut bien
comprendre que tout ce qui explique aux
gens ils en donnent qu'une partie et
nous on veut tout la main de tout
connaître sur la retraite il ya aussi
cette réforme des retraites aussi qui
nous préoccupe bien sûr c'est ce que
j'ai enfin de vous expliquer c'est ce
que je l'expliquais c'est c'est assez
flou mais ils ont des fiches en 2019
aussi et c'était pas que la retraite
aussi les agressions mais quand même pas
mal de choses qui étaient dans le
package on va dire ça comme ça mais oui
pour la retraite
la retraite c'est trop fou on a des
grands digne mais sans avoir vraiment
les barrières exactement en savoie on
peut se passer personne ne comprend rien
lors qu'il est ou très peu de choses
c'est une grande inconnue en fait c'est
tout est flou on ne sait pas donc
commencer patent qui a rien d'écrit noir
sur blanc est signé du ministre eh bien
on sera dans la rue voilà il ya
plusieurs pompiers qui j pv qui me
parlait d'un manque de reconnaissance
dans la profession oui parce que vous
savez c'est un métier assez particulier
on voit les coulisses de la vie donc on
est en première ligne pour tous dans
tous les domaines
on en prend plein la figure que ce soit
pareil pour tous les domaines
à un moment c'est bon on est dans
l'ombre depuis des années alors c'est
bon on a là on a la population qui est
quand même derrière nous parce qu'on
leur vient en aide régulièrement
enfin tout le temps j'ai envie de vous
dire mais il ya un moment fou soit
reconnue alors c'est pour ça qu est ce
qu on nous expliquera finances qui s'est
passé tout à l'heure ici je
c'est un passé grand chose des collègues
qui ce que les balles et les barricades
sans rien faire de mal parce qu'elles
sont à bouger et ont sorti les cannois
vinci code placé qua non du spectacle
merci à vous pour ce témoignage vous
l'avez entendu à grégory pour l'instant
des manifestants on est sapeur-pompier
qui restent mobilisés et qui attendent
ce qui va en ressortir de cette réunion
qui était prévue avec le gouvernement
aux alentours de 14 heures
merci mon amoud et l'or en direct donc
de cette manifestation des pompiers pour
dénoncer le manque d'effectifs et de
reconnaissance de leur profession et
réclamé des garanties pour leur retraite
est également demandé une
hausses de leurs primes de 5 % du
salaire de base entre 10 9% actuellement
on voit des gaz lacrymogènes ici du côté
des bars pompe
certains pompiers certains manifestants
tentent d'enfoncer
[Musique]